- There has never been a
low of me wearing a shoe.
There's never been
a worry about,
“Oh, I stepped my
shoe in the mud,”
or “I spilled a fruit
punch, you know, on my shoes,”
or whatever the case may be.
I've never been
that type of person.
Shoes are meant to be worn.
They supposed to have they own
lives and they own stories.
♪♪♪
If I could think of any other shoe
that has amazing significance,
I've always loved WWE.
I was a big John Cena fan.
And I remember he was wearing
these shoes that pump up.
And I was like, “Man, what
shoe he keep pumping up?
And then he goin’
and hit someone
with the Attitude Adjustment with.”
We ain't have no money, I mean,
and making ends meet week by
week was already hard enough.
Now you got me
saying, “Hey, Dad, you know, I
think I could get my basketball
game to the next level
if you put the right
shoes on my feet.”
And it was my
birthday coming up.
I was like, “You know what?
For my birthday, I don't
want nothing else but just
these pumps.”
Man, he found a
way to get me them.
I remember he
worked some overtime
and got me those shoes.
My dad already worked six jobs.
So the fact that he had to do
overtime on top of the six jobs
shows you the commitment
he did to get me the shoes.
And man, I was pumpin’
them things everywhere.
I walked outside, pump.
Mom says something, pump.
Was on the court, pump.
Score a basket, pump.
Celebration.
Like, I had it all goin’
with the pump.
And those pumps have
a great story with me.
They have a great time
in my life as well.
This shoe, these
were playoff PEs.
They were only made
for the playoffs.
I designed it in a way where
the person wearing the shoe
would find motivation every
single day in wearing the shoe.
And they may see something
different every day
that may give ‘em more
of a drive to keep going.
You see a lot of
sayings that I thought
of or I have been
told: Just breathe.
Be positive. Be you. Believe.
If I was a little kid and I was
playing the game of basketball,
and maybe I'm not doing
as well as I wanted to do,
that shoe could
give you a reminder
just to breathe, enjoy
life, enjoy the moment.
Enjoy the present cuz
the future is imagination
and the past is
learning and a gift, so.
I wanted to
create something more
of, like, a movement, a culture,
something that breeds
positivity and
great mental health.
I think it's always about
telling the story of the shoe
without having to physically
write the story out for people.
I would wanna do something
that has materials
that come from
Dominican Republic.
Doing something super
cool and different,
like incorporating
cane sugar from DR
into the sole and materials
that come from Africa
and finding ways to
get some of the fabrics
for the shoes that could have
a resemblance of being back
to the motherland.
And I think the shoe should
have versatility, so maybe
like a mid, you know? Kind of like a
mid-feeling basketball shoe
or a lifestyle shoe where it
could go with the high feel.
It could go with the low feel.
If you wanted to
skateboard in it, you can.
If you wanted to play basketball
at a high level in it, you can.
There's a lotta work to do.
But the actual execution
of it...you never know.
You gave me an idea.
Maybe I’ll start one.